here we go from the New York Post Joy
Behar rips heterosexual men for
supporting tackle football
I just I just what I got to hear from
Joy's mouth first of all hold on there a
minute she's saying that gay dudes don't
like football like I don't think that's
true I don't think your preference has
anything to do with are you like a sport
or don't you know I know you guys love
football so that's but you know what
this is all about this story is because
a dude got tackled and his heart stopped
right and so what they're trying to
blame is that he got tackled uh
correction the dude tackled the other
guy it wasn't even him right correct hot
yeah good job he tackles a guy and then
uh what are they calling it uh camachio
Cardiff yeah so
well my understanding of that was
because we talked about the other day is
that when a kid a young adult gets hit
by a baseball or a puck
they can 90. yeah it hits their heart at
the right moment and can cause a
disruption in their heart heart rhythm
that is not the same as someone's
someone who's 24 just having their
hearts stop because they have fell on
the ground right and they have a routine
tackle too I think it was the doctor
Victory what's you know her first name
is she goes on um Dr Drew a lot Victory
Dr Victory I think that's her last name
uh but she was saying I mean that's why
they're padded up so they've never seen
I think they might she might have to say
they've never seen commercial quartus in
football I don't know if you guys ever
heard I don't know for sure so don't
quote me on that but I mean they say
it's all one in 200 million sorry to cut
you off if you remember um Will Smith
the whole movie and the whole thing with
CTE the whole thing was Brain Brain
Brain Brain Brain like you're you're
familiar with what I'm talking about
what movie so Will Smith did I don't
remember what it was called but Will
Smith they produced a whole movie and
the NFL hated it because it was like
showing the reality of CTE and like NFL
players banging their heads around and
now all of a sudden their hearts are
exploding forget CT forget your brain
it's a total different part so like why
can't we talk about how the NFL was
discussing CTE every day every month
every year Brain Brain Brain Brain Brain
now we're seeing athletes just drop dead
it's not their brain that's their heart
so it's it's a totally different I mean
doctors let me read this they were
saying there's 29 deaths per year in
athletics and now there's like 1600s
1101. let me let me read this from New
York Post The View co-host Joy Behar hit
conservatives and heterosexual men on
Wednesday are you kidding 45 of
Americans think that tackle football is
appropriate heterosexual men voted the
most support for kids doing football and
conservatives were more likely to
support youth tackle football just
saying yo are we really we're going for
sarcastic ball you guys remember that
yeah South Park basketball yeah they
were it was like they played with
balloons and they had to wear bras yeah
and they ran around this this is coming
soon and uh I I you know wait until she
finds out crazy yeah I can't wait to see
her reaction like MMA everything is
polarizing I remember when they um like
six months ago they were like if you
work out you're more conservative I was
like even if that is why are we more
likely to get into a car accident yeah
that was crazy man that was crazy
imagine believing this stuff like okay
hold on let me just tell you it is
probably true that if you are
unvaccinated you're more likely to get
in a car accident why because people who
live in lockdown cities are more likely
to get vaccinated because of vaccine
mandates less likely to drive people who
live in the countryside not around
people less likely to get vaccinated
more likely to drive so they're doing
the spurious correlation uh that that is
parody worthy but there are people who
genuinely believe that and fear like oh
no I might get in a car accident unless
I get a booster shot I have a total
opposite and and hopefully it'll get
shut down for this it's not
misinformation uh knowing Malone very
personally he told me over a year ago he
said hey you know being the uh Korea is
somewhat of somewhat contributing
towards mRNA he said he's like there's
going to be this was over a year ago he
said there's going to be athletes
there's going to be car accidents
there's gonna be all these things from
people who are reacting poorly to a
vaccine and I couldn't believe him I was
like I don't believe so so I feel that
this article that you're referring to is
the opposite is to deter you from maybe
more maybe that's real maybe more
accidents which article the car accident
the one that you're discussing that oh
unvaccinated more a car accident blah
blah to kind of deter you from the true
fact that potentially could be real if
assuming Malone is right or wrong that
if you you he was saying that you have a
heart attack at the wheel he was saying
that you have some sort of thing that is
connected to this that it's like now you
can't drive now maybe but here's the
deal we have one so I think it was um uh
Corey what's his first name Peter Corey
Pierre Corey I know the Brogan's doctor
right is that he said uh he's the one
who's on he was on Tucker the other
night and he said
1101 deaths uh from like you know heart
related things or other athletes I think
that's I think that's my color that was
McCullough
oh okay sorry sorry that was McCullough
he's a cardiologist so you got to put
that in perspective if if they gave out
400 million vaccines and we saw a
thousand people die that's a very very
very very very very small
but is that the reality is this what we
know it to be but those are the numbers
being documented how many of those
numbers are not being done and for the
United States to still use the various
system an outdated system that is
extremely complicated
it absolutely makes no sense at all so
obviously we we should be doing more
reporting we should actually know the
data we should actually see what's going
on here we should see the results right
of the of this larger medical
intervention we're not seeing any of
that we have a lot of nonsensical
hyperbolic dribble by Joy behard talking
about a masculinity being a big problem
here obviously a hot take from the
corporate media testosterone bad gee
whiz who would have thought this joy and
uh Andrew Tate just gotta [ __ ] it out
right now sorry can I curse on this no
that's positive yeah
I'm sorry this is a family-friendly show
for 15 seconds if you swear in the first
15 seconds I think they demonetize the
video scale actually I think no but for
the national conversation to be about
Joy behard talking about the problems of
masculinity and not what's really going
on here and not people asking questions
why are people dropping you know you
know dropping dead here suddenly that to
me is the biggest travesty of Injustice
here because when you're on a national
television you know you have a duty to
talk about all the important stuff
you're just literally reading from the
same script reading from the same agenda
men bad balls bad testosterone bad I
mean come on
I worked I worked in the same building
as these people I used to take the
elevator down there I'd see like Whoopi
Goldberg right when I worked for they
believe the The Things They believe
about all of this dude they are not
smart people they don't read right they
sit down and they're like what's the
news and then someone's like uh if a
football player got tackled and died
whoa and they sit down and they do a
show kind of like this but without
actually pulling up Source material so
they'll go I heard that Donald Trump
said he liked white supremacists and
they really believe wow yeah they all
they do read but it's the teleprompter
right right and it's like what lines
what what do we have to say today okay
got it you know this show brought to you
by Pfizer I want to push back on what
you're saying Luke that people aren't
speaking up about it enough because I
think they are now and especially Dr
Drew pinski I'm the corporate media no
well YouTube which is Corporate Google
owns you know but uh Dr Kelly Victory Dr
Byram Bridal Dr Drew on Dr Drew's
YouTube channel they are talking about
incredible things that would have got
them banned a year ago but you're right
and they're getting downranked and not
even knowing that you're getting down I
know he's got 8 000 views on that video
are you kidding me it was out he should
be getting hundreds of thousands of
views on his algorithms specifically
make sure that it's only the approved uh
channels only the channels that are
financed by Pfizer that gets to control
the conversation here so when you look
up those specific terms on YouTube you
only get shown the corporate media which
is financed by Pfizer any independent
voice even daring to raise questions
here any scientist any independent
thinker even addressing these issues
automatically even if they're for the
narrative downranked in the algorithm
not shown to anyone and this is how they
control the conversation in this country
and how they're able to get away with
all this nonsense because people can't
even find out what's really going on
here they have they have they have such
a control of this psychological
operation that people can't even find
out what's going on here to be fair to
counter I just checked we are the top
live stream on YouTube right now good
but but is YouTube putting us in the
trending subject is YouTube highlighting
that I don't know I hope so it should
Trend us dudes this is awesome we should
I mean the amount of views we get on the
show every night it should reach
trending but it never does no no it's
paid for sure but as Independent Media
we have to literally it's like pulling
teeth in order to to kind of retain our
audience in order to keep our audience
it's it's extremely difficult as as
YouTube has been going out of their way
and doing one underhanded thing after
another underhanded thing in order to
stifle your ability to reach people and
it's not like you know the corporate
media that has an unfair advantage and
whenever you search for anything it's
always them that you get to see you
don't get to see the real voices the
corporate media I am the
um the establishment media CNN MSNBC CBS
News NBC News the the same news networks
that of course uh are controlled and
have top agents at the CIA at the the
helm in charge of those those news
organizations that are essentially are
are not news organizations they're
propaganda Outlets that do the bidding
of the special interest class that's
exactly what they are they're not in the
business of news they're in they're in
the business of propaganda yeah I think
uh to add some Nuance to what you're
saying that yeah it YouTube is probably
responsible they're just following
orders but you're still responsible for
pulling the trigger you know Soldier but
I think that the government we're gonna
find out like what they did with Twitter
that they're sending alphabet of course
of course it's got it on they got their
thumb on it just one absolutely
absolutely on Drew's video it says get
the latest information from the CDC like
there's a code a warning on it no I've
seen that's not that's not Google's show
I mean maybe alphabet's like let's do I
think it's if you probably if the guy
tell me to get a vaccine Joe Biden like
what he's talking about doctor sorry to
cut you off no no no I'm I'm I'm slowly
but if you think the Twitter files are
bad imagine what the alphabet files are
going to be like I mean if they ever
come up which they probably won't but
that's a whole nother layer of
significance finagling of our discourse
I want to know what Joe Biden was
talking to uh talking about in the
Virgin Islands oh yeah he went down
there and then the next day the
prosecutor got fired oh well sort of
tell me the story on uh December 27th
process uh AG in Virgin Islands files a
lawsuit against JP Morgan for
facilitating Epstein's trafficking that
same day Joe Biden then flies to the
Virgin Islands and then it was announced
the next week the Attorney General got
fired which makes me three days after
filing and here's the best part here's
the best part the article about Biden
flying the Virgin Islands was like he
goes there for the holidays he has not
been there for years and he decided to
just go now and it's like dude I saw
that he's not been there I didn't know
this story I heard like you know you had
Republicans that were like I can't
believe he's doing the same things that
they accused Trump for I'm like wow like
I've never been the what's really going
on guys this is a distraction I try not
to be that guy but what you're saying he
had not gone to the Virgin Islands since
he was VP that makes total sense so like
this abrupt middle of the week trip on a
Tuesday they're like in between the
holidays on Tuesday he's going to Virgin
Islands get out here yeah and Biden has
a history of firing International
politicians that he doesn't like or
investigators that don't do what he
wants them to do as he openly bragged on
the Council on Foreign Relations with
Richard Haas about how he was able to
fire a Ukrainian prosecutor that was
looking into the business that his son
was getting lucrative contracts from uh
also it was on the board of yeah yeah
yeah and and getting a lot of contracts
getting a lot of money uh getting I
think it was like what was it fifty
thousand dollars eighty three eighty
three thousand dollars a million bucks a
year and the doj still has a lot of
those doc documents surrounding his
contracts all the money all the
paychecks all the gifts that he was
getting from Russia from China from
Ukraine they're not really releasing any
of that information and for Joe Biden to
go to the Virgin Islands the Virgin
Islands that are looking for a federal
bailout and three days after announcing
this lawsuit in the Virgin Islands this
attorney general gets fired without
cause without reason the attorney
general that was looking after JP Morgan
and Chase and their involvement in this
larger trafficking and extortion
operation give me a break how more
obvious could it get this attorney
general was a hero she was she was
putting everything on the line
investigating and calling out the bigger
players and the bigger names when it
came to the biggest banks finagling and
running an international child
trafficking operation that of course
affected people in so many negative ways
thousands of children hurt and we're
never going to get any justice here
because the people who are looking into
this are being fired immediately imagine
going back in time like 2016 and telling
your past self
about that story
like you're just sitting there with
sunglasses on you guys are and you're
like hey uh younger Tim uh child sexual
trafficking rings on private islands
with powerful Global Elites and
politicians Israel you better you might
as well just go put it here's what you
want to do here's what you got to do you
gotta go back in time tell your young
yourself get a jar a big one a big like
flower jar all right empty it out and
then take a piece of paper write Alex
Jones was right tape it to the front put
the lid on top cut a hole through it put
some money in the start putting money in
it now you'll trust me trust me because
you get in front of the interest
you know that one and that when Alex
comes to collect you know you'll have uh
you'll have paid up in advance if I
would have told myself this 10 years ago
I would have been like yeah obviously
done so I'm talking about it right now
uh because because I was uh
imagine there's a guy walking around
with like a trench coat on and like a
boot on his head or and like tin foil in
his hands and he's he's yelling about
this and then it turns out he's right
who is that guy that's uh what's that
guy's name he runs for president every
so often the Buddha said his verminster
yeah Vermin Supreme what's up Luke were
you red pilled before 9 11 uh no after
but that was a big one that was a huge
one how long after uh a few years
um obviously uh around the war in Iraq
time
um I I remember still going out to my
first protest against the Iraq War uh
before it even started and uh I was
still very young then uh but I was
reading a lot of different books uh
Behold a Pale Horse was one of the books
that I was reading when I was like 14 15
and uh what was at these events because
now now that I'm been to similar ones in
modern time essentially like to me that
that almost seems like I feel like I was
late were they Republicans at these
events like people that voted for Bush
maybe or no well right after 9 11 the
Republican Party had control of of
everything had had the seat at the table
they were in charge right and they were
able to Galvanize a huge amount of power
and authority for themselves and then
they ended up bankrupting in this
country and starting Foreign Wars and
destroying people's personal Liberties
and I think this is why the woke culture
is so prevalent today because there was
such a big pushback as you as you were
describing to the bush years which were
absolutely horrible when the Republicans
had control of every institution had the
nation saying just tell us what to do
we'll follow your orders uh you know
let's roll right they were cheering them
on they screwed this country over they
screwed their people over and the
National Security State that was built
to fight terrorism is being turned
around and being used against the same
kind of Republicans right that dared to
speak up so uh what happened with the
bush years was absolutely mind-boggling
it was absolutely crazy and of course
the right wing media then attacked us
and then Barack Obama came into power
and then the left-wing media attacked us
right uh because it's about you know
being open-minded it's about being
critical of any kind of power and anyone
else establishment no matter what is
that picture of Kevin McCarthy with the
Ukraine pen real
I think he had
um I think there's a photo of him with
the pin and then the flag yeah posted
the picture
who knows what's true these days because
there's a lot of you know disinformation
or propaganda everywhere a lot you know
Photoshop it's very you know did you
think that the weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq was real when you
heard it uh no there was uh uh there was
a un weapon inspector that came out and
was screaming no there are no weapons of
mass destruction This Is A Lie the New
York Times was again given fake
information by the intelligence agencies
and then reported absolutely they have
weapons of mass destruction meanwhile
other people were saying that it's it's
very unlikely that they do and if they
have anything it's probably the weapons
that we gave them in order to fight Iran
when Iran and Iraq were fighting
together and the United States was
backing both sides and giving them
weapons in orders for them to kind of
take each other out what happened
between 9 11 and then like 2003 that
that made you become like uh critical of
it because I was still like in it I was
still in The Matrix in that point well I
grew up in New York City I saw the
police state kind of be built up I was
affected by the police state and seeing
it all around me and then seeing the
larger kind of discussion seeing people
be tortured seeing people be uh you know
seeing those photos from from uh from
Guantanamo Bay that has an impact on it
and then uh when Alex Jones crept up
behind Luke with a red pill and grabbed
him by the hair and then put it in his
mouth I like when he does that I
remember me and my friends
back then to get a video you needed to
be on the dial up computer right you
needed to be on torrents and you would
slowly download a video for two to three
days sometimes even longer and you would
torch the video and then you would
finally open it you never knew what you
were getting there wasn't any thumbnail
right people and and then many times
what we used to do we used to no no no
no no we used to upload deterrents of
all the movies that came out so the
original Matrix came out and instead of
putting the Matrix we put 911 wrote to
tyranny which was Alex Jones's first
documentary and then people would
download all the turrets and upload it
automatically yeah this is way way back
in the day and I remember the first time
being a young teenager uh going to my
friend's uh apartment he he took all
week downloaded uh Alex Jones
documentary we were watching it we heard
police cars outside and we're like
they're coming across because of the
paranoia and the fear-mongering that was
around them actually you know impacted
Us in such a way but but but at the end
of the day he he released so much
important information that no one else
was talking about that this was the
underground of the underground and
people were watching these videos
because people were re-uploading alleged
the new the new latest movie friend you
would take one of these videos put the
Matrix title on it right and then people
would click it when they opened up
drawing people from The Matrix I mean
that's very a double on top whatever
movie came out right we made sure to
re-upload the tour music was the same
way it was like Crank That Soulja Boy
and it was like I did not have sexual
relations yeah yeah I was like I just
try to download Crank That social boy
like sheesh I'm eight years old I'm like
who is this piracy you wouldn't download
a car would you that's right isn't it
kind of funny how piracy is just gone
yeah like the market solved that problem
correct right now you just pay eight
bucks a month or whatever it was easier
than downloading unzipping plugging your
phone in whatever whatever the yeah it
could be a three megabyte I never knew
what you were getting it would take like
12 hours like a three megabyte I'd do it
so it's like I'm gonna pay four or five
bucks and I guess I'd rather pay and
know what I'm getting than not paying
like not know what I'm yeah you download
a song and it would be like you know
you're trying to download Nickelback but
you end up with some weird random band
you know I used to down all the kids
love Nickelback I would like download
games I was torrenting games right yeah
Crusader Kings too and then I liked it
so much that I ended up buying it
because I love the developers deserved
it then I bought a second copy because I
love it I'm willing to it I wouldn't
have known that it was awesome and I
wouldn't have bought two copies so I I
just that I just I don't and then
everyone clapped I don't believe it I
bought it for my friend for friends
because if you have expansions then your
friends can play multiplayer and they
get to use your expansions it's such a
good uh sales tool for a game I remember
those LimeWire days it was so exciting
because like you never knew what you
were getting no you didn't like that you
enjoyed that which virus are you getting
this time it was it was interesting
because it was it was a way of of people
being able to kind of communicate with
each other share videos share photos and
then it wasn't like there was you know a
720 or or 4K people are spoiled today
people are absolutely spoiled but you
were able to find things like Alex Jones
accidentally uh things like William
Cooper as uh broadcast accidentally
um and there was I forgot who else was
there was there was a couple other
um ogs out there that were releasing
videos and documentaries that were
archaic that were done through Public
Access television that were pretty
revolutionary and Alex Jones uh you know
you know say what you made about him but
he was he he he he he he blazed the path
forward when he came to Independent
Media when it came to critical thinking
and he was one of the first people to
say hey I don't need the corporate media
I don't need to be approved I don't need
multi-millions of dollars I'm going to
show up at this local broadcasting
station and I'm gonna do things on my
own and release it to the general public
and it went viral so truly give him
credit because he was one of the first
independent content creators that
actually was able to be successful with
all of this and then of course came
loose change and everyone pirated that
and that was its biggest strength that's
how it became so popular because of that
kind of virality because of that kind of
need because of that thirst for
knowledge and hunger and it was like you
could get anything and everything online
but also you get a whole bunch of
surprises so it was it was a wild west
back in the day and it was way better
than what it is now thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time